now there's another crazy guy I don't
know whether to take him seriously in
this field or not he's called Andrea
Rossi he has something called the energy
catalyzer um I think one can be
justifiably skeptical about his work
because Randall Mills has an
organization that people have invested I
don't know $140 million in it's a
serious organization and the Japanese
effort is involved with universities
industry the government that's a serious
thing but this guy Andre RI seems to you
know keep all the close to his chest
he's doing it all on his own it's a
little crazy but he claims now he had
more conventional low energy or lce
enabled nuclear reactions much closer to
ponon fashun already 10 years ago but
now he claims he's getting energy out of
the vacuum you know out of quantum
fluctuations in the vacuum